[Music]
sorry to interrupt are you okay I need
to get out of a toxic relationship
why don't you start by telling us what
brought you here
my boss is different you can't get him
out of your head no I need your
assistance
oh you felt like he could destroy you
with the snap of his fingers wouldn't
even need to snap
okay oh that sounds familiar yeah what
[Music]
I want 100 nouns a bus load of
cheerleaders
and I just want to know
This Modern World Is A Dangerous Place
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you you saved my life did I watch
you cut a guy with a decorative serving
platter it's own the rest
let me explain my boss gave me this
power
in return I tend to his needs including
care feeding you bring and people to eat
you're like the guy that gets the
villain's Postmates but if you were to
stop focusing on his needs what would
happen
he won't grow to full power exactly he
won't grow to full power what that's so
weird why would you phrase it like that
but yes
are you here for the meeting well come
on
come call me the dark one oh there's the
Lord of deaths to most
I am
okay obviously we're dealing with a
little bit more than just narcissism
here
[Music]
[Music]